Philadelphia man sentenced to life in
prison in 2009 for killing his friend is
free this morning Dante Patterson was
exonerated yesterday after an
extraordinary court motion from
Philadelphia's district attorney he
asserted Patterson's conviction was
quote an egregious example of police and
prosecutorial misconduct Michelle Miller
spoke with the 29 year-old who always
insisted he was innocent
Michelle good morning good morning he
did indeed well the case is stirring up
controversy between Philadelphia's new
DA and the former prosecutor who secured
Patterson's conviction Patterson had
been on house arrest since March after
his conviction was vacated and today
he's a free man Donte Patterson ran into
a childhood friend as he was about to
have the monitoring device on his ankle
removed one of the first things he did
pick up his 11-year old daughter at her
bus stop you've seen her grow up without
being with her what kind of pain did
that bring to you these are cars a judge
dropped all charges against Patterson at
the request of newly installed district
attorney Larry crasner we were able to
show the prosecutor in this matter
there was a lot of evidence that they
had not considered or seen Patterson was
arrested in 2007 for the murder of his
friend antwine Jackson his first trial
in 2008 ended in a hung jury he was
convicted at a retrial in 2009 the DA's
office claimed this week that although
Patterson was tried twice neither jury
heard the truth adding the prosecution
and police did not turn over strong
evidence in their possession that
identified the likely perpetrator the
motion says another unnamed suspect was
killed just a few months after Jackson's
murder
I think antwine Jackson's killer was
released today
retired prosecutor Richard sax handled
Patterson's second trial I resent that
they said I withheld evidence
because I did not and never have and had
never been shown to or established by
any court that I have so that's nonsense
Marisa Bluestein is the executive
director of the Pennsylvania Innocence
Project which has been working on
Patterson's case for the last four years
that prosecutor has always seen this
case through the lens of Dante
Patterson's guilty and he is caught up
in that narrative and that narrative is
very tight to him you can't get these 11
years back how do you move on take it
day by day step by step no just got
Steve's home this is the latest case in
Pennsylvania where someone who spent
years behind bars was cleared rapper
Meek Mill was freed just last month DA
Harry crasner has campaigned and
campaigned as a reformer who described a
city's district attorney's office as
hell-bent on winning cases at any cost
now in this country last year 139 people
were exonerated a hundred and seventy
one the year before that that's on
average about three every week so this
really gives weight to people who say
the system is broken and something needs
to be done the impact it has on so many
family members too you see it right
there you know you think about the
Innocence Project those people who
dedicate their lives to these cases were
they not there this wouldn't have
happened yeah yeah you have all kinds of
innocence projects all over this country
with different missions some that look
at it from the DNA process others who
look at it from the technicality process
that's with Aaron Moriarty's piece just
earlier this week Michelle thank you